YIGIT BOYAR: Oh, good
morning, everybody.
Welcome to the Advanced
Data Binding session.
I'm Yigit Boyar.
GEORGE MOUNT: I'm
George Mount and we're
from the Android UI Toolkit,
part of the Framework team
on Android.
And today let's talk a little
bit about data binding.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YIGIT BOYAR: [LAUGHS]
GEORGE MOUNT: All right.
So how many of you have used
data binding in the past?
All right.
How many people think
it's still in beta?
All right, yeah.
Yeah, that's the problem.
We didn't do a great
announcement last fall
when we released it with
Android Studio [? 2.15. ?]
But it is production now.
And you are welcome to use it.
It's production quality.
It's actually doing
very well in the public.
So if you haven't seen it, I
have put a little link here
for our previous
Android data binding
talk at Android Dev Summit.
And you can just click on this.
If you're watching
at home, that's
a great thing to do right now.
Pause it and go see that link.
Because we're going to
show you about four minutes
a quick version of what we did
for about 40 minutes back then.
YIGIT BOYAR: It's good.
GEORGE MOUNT: All right.
So what is data binding?
Well, when we have
a layout like this--
this is my awesome store.
And what I want to
do-- because of course,
I want to get data
into my layout.
And of course, I have
to find the views that
are in my layout.
And then set the
data, all right?
This kind of sucks, right?
I hate doing this.
So we just use
Android data binding.
So let's look at
that layout again.
OK, we want to get rid
of all that setter logic.
That kind of sucks.
FindViewByID really is lousy.
But we have to do something
a little different
in the onCreate.
Instead of calling
setContentView,
we have to have a different
setContentView, which
will create a data binding.
And then we have to set the
data object on that binding.
We can't do only that, though.
We have to modify our
layout just a little bit.
First thing we have to
do is add the layout tag
to the outside of this.
And of course, we move
the namespace stuff
up to the top in the layout tag,
because that's the right thing
to do.
And we have a data tag as well.
It has all the variables
that we're going to use.
In this case, it's
prod for our product.
So that kind of does our
import or sets the variables
that we're going to
use in our layout.
And then we also have
to reference those.
So we assign the values
directly to our source, or text,
or anything else that
we have in our layout.
And here, you can see that we
can use any expression we want.
And we just has the @{ to denote
that it's a data-bound tag.
Let's see how it works.
YIGIT BOYAR: So data binding
looks way too magical.
And you want to briefly
explain that there's actually
more magic.
And like, there's
well-defined steps
how we prepare that is
good for you to know,
because then you have an idea
what's going behind the scenes.
If you get a problem,
you have an idea
where it might be happening.
So while you hit Run
in Android Studio,
the Android Studio starts
compiling your application.
And it merges your resources.
And when the layout
files are merged,
we go pick those
layout files, and then
remove everything
about data binding.
So like everything you put
there about data binding gets
deleted.
So if you put layout with
something data binding,
you lose it.
And then in next step, we
parse these expressions,
so that they are
grammatically correct.
We don't know what you
put makes sense or not,
but they need to be
grammatically correct.
So when we parse, we understand,
OK, there's some, like,
identifiers here.
Accessing your field,
we have no idea
what that is at this stage.
But we know it's correct.
And if it's not, we
will throw an exception.
And next step, your
application code gets compiled.
Like, the Java code you
write gets compiled.
While it's being
compiled, we [? have an ?]
annotation processor that
gets the outputs from what
we parse from the
layout files and tries
to understand what it means.
So let's say you had
something like user.admin.
Now you declare the variable.
We know there was
some user cost there.
We go and find that cost.
Then we try to figure out,
OK, what does isAdmin mean?
Like, is this a method call?
Is this a field?
We figured it out.
We [? will be ?] resulting
like this is admin method,
or you could just
say user.admin.
We will still understand that
this is an is.admin Boolean
method.
And then figure out, OK,
this grammatically correct
expression resolves
into a Boolean value.
Now, when we look
at the attribute,
I will try to find, OK, what
is the setter we need to call?
Is this Visibility integer, or
enabled, whether we resolve it?
And all of this happens
while your application
is being compiled.
Whilst we decide what to
do, we write the binders
to the actual code
that updates the UI.
And you profit.
So really briefly, this
is data-bound layout file.
At the time of compile,
we literally do this.
Like, delete everything.
We try to keep the
files, the lines
match as much as possible.
If you go check your
[? real ?] file,
you will find the
stripped files.
So we get rid of
that layout tag.
Then we get rid of
everything data-binding,
because APT doesn't
know about them.
We clean them.
And then we hit some tags,
so that-- go ahead, OK--
so that when you inflate
layout, we can understand
[? which field is. ?] This is
why even if you don't put IDs
on those [? fields, ?]
we find them.
So George has some
presents for you.
[LAUGHTER]
GEORGE MOUNT: So that's what
we released back in the fall.
Let's see what new
things we have here.
Two-way data binding.
Now, I know I've heard
a lot from you guys out
there that say, you
know, this is great,
but without two-way
data binding,
data binding's useless, right?
I can't believe I heard that.
But I think even one-way data
binding is pretty awesome.
So I saw a few people
trying to do their own thing
for two-way data binding.
And they'd do
something like this,
where they'd do the one-way
data binding with the regular
data-binding field, and then
add another handler for the text
change.
And then they'd have
to check, of course,
whether the change really
happened, or else you end up
with this cycle of loops of
the text changes in the view,
and then it goes
back to the field,
and it sends a text
change message.
So it was kind of a mess.
And also, you end up
having this change handler
for every different bound
view in your layout.
And it really kind of sucked.
So we wanted to do something
a little better than this.
Get rid of all that stuff
that you're used to.
And we can do this all on our
own by just saying @= instead
of just @{, right?
The @= is just kind of a
nice quick and very visible
indicator that this is a
two-way data-bound field.
Now we can bind to
the Android text
field in a very simple way.
Now, you may be wondering, how
does this notification happen?
What's going on
underneath the hood?
This is kind of
important if you were
going to write your
own data-bound fields.
So first thing we have to
know is what kind of listener
should we add?
We don't want to
use TextWatcher,
because that's only useful
for text views or edit text.
We don't want to use--
I don't know, what?
YIGIT BOYAR: Time change.
GEORGE MOUNT: Time change.
Yeah, date change or
something like that.
That wouldn't be good.
So we have some
kind of generic one.
It's called the inverse
binding listener.
And this is basically
telling us that there's
been a change on your view.
And what happens is
your binding implements
this listener for you.
And this is code almost straight
out of the generated code.
So you can see here
that what's going on
is it's getting the
text from the view.
And then it does, of
course, null checking.
You guys have to make sure
to do all null checking.
Everyone here always
double-checks their variables,
right?
OK?
Everyone?
Yeah.
I see.
YIGIT BOYAR: You're not
using data-binding, though.
[LAUGHTER]
You don't need null checks.
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah.
YIGIT BOYAR: It's 2016.
GEORGE MOUNT:
Yeah, that's right.
Who has no pointer exceptions?
I don't know.
Nobody.
YIGIT BOYAR: Which language?
GEORGE MOUNT: And then it
finally sets the field.
You can see here that it's
actually setting this field
as an observable field.
And actually, you might
be interested to see
that this comment here is
actually in the generated code.
So if you wanted to go look
at that generated code,
you'll see this
comment and see what
the inverse of
this expression is
to help you try to debug if
you have a problem with it.
So let's look at how you
get that field's value.
We just saw that--
getting the field's value.
And one thing to do is to
try to annotate the quickest
annotation, which will give
you a getter for your view.
So here we have
a text view type.
And we want to know what is
the getter for android:text.
Now, we have this method.
We can just declare it.
It's a getText.
But if you don't supply
it, there's a default.
And it just uses
the attribute name.
So even if we didn't supply
anything, it would use getTest,
because the attribute
is android:text.
So it's kind of smart that way.
And we have this
synthetic attribute.
This is for the event.
This is the event that
notifies that there's
been a change in that view.
And again, there's
a default here.
If we didn't supply
anything, it would be
android:textAttrChanged.
So most of the time, you
wouldn't supply anything here
at all.
Now I want to talk a
little bit more about this.
So we, of course, have
to get notifications
from the text view.
And so this is what you'd
normally do for a text view.
You have to set a TextWatcher.
And so we have these
event attributes
in the binding adapter.
And so we just add
this other attribute,
the synthetic attribute.
Now, the synthetic
attribute-- you
can't use this in your layout.
We check against it.
So if you try to
do that, it's going
to throw up a nice exception for
you or error message for you.
But anyway, so you can now set
this in your binding adapter.
And this is, of course,
all done for you
for all the fields that work.
And of course, what
do you have to do?
You have to remove
the previous one,
and then you have
to add a new one.
And you have to notify them
only if they're not null, right?
We don't want to
notify null things,
because we, of course,
want to do null checking.
And we also have to notify
our onChange [? Lister ?].
So now we know that when
that text views changes,
it's going to call our
generated onChange.
Now, if you have a more
complex getter-- well,
this is not very complex, but
this is a little more complex.
The text view doesn't return
a string, it returns what?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah.
Char sequence, right?
And who here uses
char sequences?
Ah, nobody uses char sequence.
If you try to assign char
sequence to a string?
Typecast error.
So this is a little
more convenient.
So you have a
getTextString, which
will automatically convert your
char sequence into a string.
And so this kind of thing
will help you with that.
And again, we have
this attribute.
And the other field is
also there-- the event.
And it's automatically
defaulted.
And we talked a little
about these cycles
before, where if you have a
text view or an edit text,
and it makes a
change, of course--
it's going to change
your data field.
And if you have a change
in the data field,
it's going to change
your [? header ?] text.
Now, that really sucks,
because what happened?
User typed A, and now it just
set the text on that again,
and you lost your cursor.
YIGIT BOYAR: Oh!
Yeah, something
you will realize.
If you set the text on a text
view, it went to the same text.
It'll still call
the change watchers,
it'll still
[? have ?] the layout,
because inside [INAUDIBLE]
actually a different
[? spendable ?] string.
It has some other format,
so we have to do that.
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah.
YIGIT BOYAR: So
data-binding gets covered.
How is that?
GEORGE MOUNT: Well,
actually, it's
going to do it more now,
because it just recognized
that there's another change.
And of course, it's going
to send another text change.
And it's going to keep on
going on and on and on.
And that kind of sucks.
Nobody wants to see infinite
cycles in data binding.
So let's solve it!
We're gonna solve it
once and for all, right?
Well, unfortunately, no.
[LAUGHTER]
But you can solve it.
And we solve it for all
the ones we've implemented.
You just have the check in
the binding adapter that says,
when you've set the text field,
we checked the previous value
and made sure that
it hasn't changed.
If it has changed,
then we'll just set it.
If it hasn't changed,
then we don't set it.
And that breaks the
cycle before we can
get this kind of infinite loop.
YIGIT BOYAR: So this
kind of solutions
we do in data binding.
So changing the framework,
that's an option for us.
But it'll only work
in the new devices.
By doing these work-arounds, we
can support data binding API 7?
GEORGE MOUNT: API
7, that's right.
So does this work
on all attributes?
Well, no.
Clearly not.
Because we need events.
We need events to know
whether the field has changed,
whether the attribute
has changed.
And so we only
work with the ones
that have change events,
so like TextWatcher,
like CheckedChanged.
So these are external events.
These are not on
whatever changed events.
So the good thing is
that almost everything
you care about already has
a change notification on it.
These are the things the
user's clicking on, right?
They're typing in
the Edit field.
So this is great.
So we already have
notifications for these.
So that will work for
almost all the attributes
that you really care about.
But if you have
your own fuse, you
need to do this, have
an external event
that you can set a listener on.
All right.
Let's talk a little bit
about expression chaining.
Now, here I have a
layout with three views.
And they all have the
same expression in it.
It's kind of ugly code.
Like, it's all UI code,
but it's a little ugly.
And I really don't
want to do that.
I'd like to have it once and
then re-use it elsewhere.
So what I can do is create
an ID that I can later
use in my other expressions.
So now we could just
bind to another field.
It's pretty nice.
What it's doing under the hood,
of course, is just saying,
oh, I recognize
that one, we already
had a bound
expression there, I'm
just going to substitute that.
We also have implied
event updates.
So you combined, for
example, to a checked field
in another view, because checked
is a two-way data bind field.
So we can just say, oh,
look, that field over there
was-- the user
clicked on it, and we
get an update right away.
We know what happened.
Let's talk a little bit
about lambda expressions.
YIGIT BOYAR: So
two-way data binding
is one way of grabbing
the data from the layout
back to your data model.
Another way is
the callback side.
[INAUDIBLE] is you
get a view, you
set a click list around that.
So we wanted to make
it a little bit better.
So in two days [? data, ?]
before we introduced this
feature, what you will do with
data binding is that you would
give the [? event ?] an ID.
And then in your Java
code, you will get an ID
from the binding.
We already create
the view for you.
And then you will set a
ClickListener on that.
So we want to make it intuitive.
We got rid of that.
We introduced method references,
so that you could say,
hey, we know
OnClick is an event.
So where does this
presenter come from?
The [INAUDIBLE] and other
variable you declare.
So there's still no magic.
It's not like the
OnClick event you
have in the activity
in the framework.
So in the Presenter,
what you would do
is-- so we will [? tightly ?]
call this method.
You will receive the
view, because onClick,
as soon as it receives the
view, you will get the binding.
So this is a cool method.
Like data binding, it
has a findBinding method
from any view.
And you will get
the item from there
and then do whatever you
want to do with that.
But this is still a lot
of unnecessary code.
So we wanted to make
this a little bit easier.
We introduced
lambda expressions.
So you get rid of that.
You could instead just
say, when onClick happens,
just call presenter.save
with the item.
Where does the item come from?
It's the item that
you declared there.
So in your same method
in the presenter,
like, you can do whatever you
want now you have the item.
What is very cool--
actually, the
reason why we pushed-- so
we had this in the timeline.
But we pushed this
feature a little bit
earlier, because
the testing team
was releasing these
architectural demos
from Google.
And for the [? MDVM, ?] they
wanted something like this.
When you do this, the presenter
has zero Android code.
So your layout file handles
everything specific to Android.
You can just test your
presenter the way you want this.
It's so beautiful separation.
It works very well and
makes it very clean.
Another very cool thing here is
that in Android Studio today,
you can go, roll over the same
function there, click on it,
and go to the Presenter.
So much easier to navigate the
code while we are developing.
So I see [? lists ?] get
a little bit more details.
So it's a lambda expression.
You can also write this.
The onClick receives a view.
So if you look at the
description of the onClick
callback class, this
is how it looks like.
So you can actually
reference that view
in the lambda expression
if you want to use it.
And then the view inside the
expression refers to the one
that you declared in
the Parameter section.
So just like the Java,
eight lambda functions.
And at least you
have-- you can actually
name it whatever you want.
So I named it v. The name
doesn't need to match anything.
So let's look at the other
example, the FocusChange.
So you want to know
when the FocusChange is.
You want to call your presenter
with whatever the new focus is.
Unfortunately, you
cannot do this,
because if you look at
[? all ?] FocusChange methods
or FocusChange clause, the
method receives the view
and the focus state.
So even if you don't want to
use the view clause, the v
parameter, you
have to declare it.
So the rule here is you either
declare all of the arguments
that the method receives,
or you declare none.
We figured out not
declaring [INAUDIBLE]
very common use case.
Like, in the ClickListener, you
almost never want to [? be ?]
[? there ?] anyways.
So we want to provide
that no-argument shortcut.
Another example is onLongClick.
Now, the difference
about onLongClick
is it actually expects a
Boolean value as a result,
so that we know we want
to populate it or not.
So for this to
work, the presenter
show many method-- also needs
to return a Boolean value.
So we are not going to-- if
you put some lambda expression
there that doesn't return the
value expected by the callback,
it's not going to compile.
We don't want to, you know, oh,
this, by default, return false.
And something breaks
in the future.
You have no idea.
So if things don't match,
we don't try to do magic.
We fail.
So there is two ways
to do the same thing.
There is the lambda expressions
and the method references.
They are both useful.
I want to go over what the
difference is, because they
actually behave differently.
So the major difference
between the two
is lambda expressions
are evaluated
when the event happens.
So whatever expression
you put there,
we evaluate it when user
clicks on a button, or the text
changes, or whatever.
The method references,
on the other hand,
is evaluated by
me refresh the UI.
When something is evaluated,
when we refresh the UI,
we evaluate the
expression, we figure out
which method wants to be
called, and set a ClickListener
that directly references
that [? one. ?]
So let's look at the example.
It will be more clear.
So the previous one
where we had a presenter,
let's say I set it to null.
And the presenters--
that same method
was linked into the same button.
So if we look at
saveButton.getClickListener,
so in this case, when
the presenter is null,
does the same button
have a ClickListener?
If you are using
lambda expressions, no.
It actually still
has a same button.
Like, this not null.
Even if you don't
have a presenter,
there's a callback in that view.
But if you are using method
references, yes, it's null.
Like, we don't set it.
So sometimes setting a view
clickable has side effects
and is important for you.
You will need to use
the method references.
But we will take
care of [INAUDIBLE].
So you are not going to crash
even if there's a callback.
When the callback
[? grounds, ?] we
will figure out there
is no presenter,
and it will just drop it.
So the way it works is when you
inflate the layout-- if you're
using lambda expression,
we inflate the layout,
we set the ClickListener.
It belongs to us.
And then when the click happens,
we evaluate the presenter,
we evaluate the parameters,
and then run it.
If you are using a
method reference, when
we execute bindings,
this is the method
that we generate
that updates the UI.
When we run that method, we
will figure out the presenter.
And if there is a
presenter, we will wrap it
in a listener class, which
calls the related method.
And if there is not, we
set the callback to null.
And the listener
clause we generate
looks like just something
simple like this.
It receives the presenter.
So we compare our
reference to that one.
And then we can call it back.
That presenter comes from
the presenter we evaluated.
Another difference is
you can use expressions.
This is the one we get
[? advantage ?] for lambda
expressions-- that you can
use any expression inside
the lambda versus you cannot
do that in method expressions.
So you could say, like,
presenter.save(user.friend).
And we will evaluate it.
Or you could say,
like, data.presenter.
Anything that's valid in data
binding, you can use it there,
and we will evaluate it.
Versus in method expressions,
you cannot do that.
And the method has
to match the event.
But you could still say, like,
data.presenter, same method.
So you can have an expression
to the beginning of it,
but you cannot change
the call parameters.
The callback parameters--
in both of them,
you can access it.
So if you are using
a presenter, you
have to declare it
yourself-- like, I
want to access the view.
So you declare the parameter.
I'm sorry.
Wrong button.
And if you are using the method
references, it already works.
It has to match.
GEORGE MOUNT: Now, you can
use a few extra variables
now in your lambda expressions
that you couldn't use before.
One of them is view IDs.
OK?
You can reference your views
right in the expression.
And it's your view ID,
and it's referenced
as the camel-casified version.
And this is the same field
that you use in your binding.
So we camel-casify it just
the way we did before.
And you can also
use the context.
We found that many of
you wanted to access
the context without
accessing a specific view.
So we just give you the
context of the root.
And you can use this as kind of
a generated, synthetic variable
that you can use right
there in your layout.
YIGIT BOYAR: But if
you create something
that's called context,
then we won't do that.
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah,
don't do that.
YIGIT BOYAR: But
please don't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah, it
will override our context
if you do that.
All right, let's talk
about animations.
Animations.
Everyone wants to use
animations in their UIs, right?
How many-- raise of hands.
YIGIT BOYAR: Yeah!
GEORGE MOUNT: That's right,
that's right. [INAUDIBLE].
YIGIT BOYAR: Motion.
GEORGE MOUNT: Get a
little motion in your UI.
Well, one of the things
you see with data binding
is without any kind
of a special work,
you get this kind of
weird thing, where
you click on something, and
it just pops into place.
And that's kind of unfortunate.
But we can do something pretty
simple to get a nice animation.
And that's use transitions.
How many of you use
transitions before?
Yeah, this is something
introduced in KitKat.
It's very useful.
You get kind of automatic
animations with it.
And what you can do is
add the onRebindCallback.
One of the functions
there is the onPreBind.
And that's the thing
we really care about.
This is evaluated before
the binding happens,
before the bindings
are evaluated.
And we don't know
what's going to happen.
We just know that
something is going
to happen when this is called.
And what we do is we
get the sceneRoot.
And then, of course, call
the beginDelayedTransition.
And then you get a nice effect.
Pretty nice.
Pretty easy.
Pretty simple.
YIGIT BOYAR: Maybe we
should make this an API.
Enable animations.
GEORGE MOUNT:
That's a good idea.
Yeah, we should do that.
But this doesn't
work with everything.
Let's look at this ad here.
When we change the
field here, which
changes the age of the user,
it just still pops in and out.
All right, our transition system
doesn't handle every transition
you might want.
It handles the most common
ones-- fading in and out,
or changing the position of the
view, those kinds of things.
And you can do your
own transitions,
but sometimes you want
something very custom,
and you just want to do
an animation for that.
So what do you do?
Well, in this case, what we
can do is do it with setting.
When the value is
actually set on the field,
we can capture the state there
and animate it ourselves.
So we create this
BindingAdapter.
And we, of course, get the
old value and the new value.
You don't have to take the
old value if you don't want,
but in this case, we do want it.
And then of course, if nothing
has changed, we have to,
of course, not do anything.
We don't want to do anything
if nothing's changed.
But then we can just animate
the change right then and there.
And you can do whatever
animation you want.
I don't know what you'd
want to do on a text field,
but you can do whatever
you want there.
Maybe cross-fade.
I don't know.
Dependency injection.
All right.
Again, show of hands.
How many people love
dependency injection?
All right.
YIGIT BOYAR: Nice.
GEORGE MOUNT: All right.
This is you guys.
This is for you.
When you're writing tests,
of course, what do you do?
When you're binding adaptors,
you have an if statement.
If it's testing settings or
you're not testing settings,
you could do one or the other.
But we're dependency
injection fans.
We don't want to do that.
That sucks.
So what we do is create
a binding adapter
that is no longer static.
So we have an abstract
binding adapter.
Of course, this could
be an interface.
It doesn't have to be
an abstract base class.
And we implement that interface
with your test version
or your production version.
But we don't know
which instance to call.
We're data binding.
We don't know whether you
want to call something
on your test or your production.
And so we need to know
what you're going to do.
So we create this
data-binding component.
Whenever we see an
instance method like that,
we know that you are going
to give us an instance.
And so you implement
the component.
This is a generated
data-binding component
that has that
generated getter in it.
And you implement that.
And you do whatever you need
to do to get your component.
But then you have
to set it as well.
So this is the default setter.
You can also do it on each
inflate call if you want.
But probably, you only want
to use one or the other.
But you can do it every time you
inflate a view or bind a view.
But you can also do it when
you're in your static binding
adapters.
You don't have to do it
just when you're doing
instance-binding adapters.
Now, I'll show you an
instance where this is useful.
So we have this system where
we're going to load an image.
And we want to load the
image using an image loader.
We have cached already.
And we want to get
that ImageLoader
instance, of course.
So of course get the component.
Well, where did that
component come from?
Well, we could get the
context, and then we
could try to find
it in the context
by casting it and [INAUDIBLE].
Kind of a pain.
So instead, what we
want to do is introduce
data-binding component.
Of course, this is
our instance one
that we have in our application.
And we can introduce it right
there in our BindingAdapter.
And then we can use it.
If you're using Dagger 2, what
you do is you create a module
and provide the method.
And then you create a component,
and you set your default
component just like that.
All right.
YIGIT BOYAR: So by the way,
if you're using data binding
but did never write a binding
adapter, play with them.
They're amazing.
You can create your
own attributes.
I'm seeing so many-- like,
we have to create them,
so we can [? backport ?]
data binding.
But they turn out to
be most widely abused,
in a good way, features
of data binding.
So one question we get
mainly is, how do I
start using data binding?
Because you already have an app.
When you start from scratch,
yeah, it's very easy.
But if you already
have an app, it
doesn't make sense to
rewrite your layouts.
This is unnecessary work.
If it works, keep it.
But in the new layouts, you
can start using data binding.
So we wanted to go
through these levels.
So to start using data binding,
you just enable it in Gradle.
Super simple.
Three lines.
And then one thing you can start
doing today in any new layout
you create is get to
the [? findViewById ?].
There is like 25,
30 libraries that
try to get to the
[? findViewById. ?]
GEORGE MOUNT: Now it's 31.
YIGIT BOYAR: Yeah.
I think 31 is the last one.
So I have never seen
anybody else creating it
after we released data binding.
This is like something
we should have released
seven years ago,
like eight years ago,
when we released Android
So you just [? rep ?] your
layout into the layout tag,
and then you are done.
Nothing else you have to do.
Now, with your code, you
had these findViewById
or had these annotations
that you put on the views.
You get rid of all of it.
You get one binding
class for that layout,
and it already has all the
views that has an ID as a field.
These are public, final fields.
And they are type-safe.
Like, you don't need casting.
If, by mistake-- like there is
one common mistake happens--
is you use the same
ID in multiple places
in different layouts.
Someone changes an
ID in one place,
your code doesn't crash
because the same ID
was used somewhere else.
But at runtime, you get a
crash, because you cannot find
the view anymore.
With data binding,
this cannot happen,
because we create
them per layout.
If someone, by mistake,
changes the ID,
it's not going to compile.
The second part is binding
the UI, this very simple way
that you can start
using data binding.
Actually, you should.
In my opinion, it's no-brainer,
but of course, I'm biased.
In every single UI,
you have this thing--
like your presenter or whatever.
Once you log the data,
you go through the data,
go through your views,
and set each of them.
You need to handle the null.
No, you need to catch them.
Blah, blah.
This is just, like,
so an unnecessary code
that you have to write.
You don't need to write.
So just get
[? rid of ?] those IDs.
Declare your variable
in the layout.
This is a layout to display
the specific information.
It's totally
intuitive to declare
the inputs of the layout there.
So you say, this layout
displays the user.
You define it and
you use it inside.
So when someone
inflates your layout
and wants to do [? only, ?]
they already the binding clause.
They could see all the setters.
They know what the input
is for that layout.
And [INAUDIBLE] update UI
method to get rid of all of it,
the only thing you do is
set it on the binding,
and it takes care of it.
All of this happens without
any performance penalty.
The third thing is callbacks.
There is always the case you get
the binding, you get the fab,
and then set the ClickListener.
This is also so unnecessary.
Just declare the presenters.
Just say, when this button
is clicked, call this thing.
The nice thing about this
implementation is you can just,
when you are in Android Studio--
it happens all the time,
s You go into a layout.
OK, what happens if
user clicks and you
try to search references
of that view ID
and then see where
the ClickListener is.
There's a couple of steps.
Here, you can just click
and go to that method,
and find implementation.
So especially if you
are starting a new app
from scratch, observability
might be very, very handy.
So instead of having
this simple user clause,
you could make extend
BaseObservable.
There's also an interface if
you don't want the extend.
You make it bindable.
And then whenever
the value changes,
you want to find this change.
And we will take care
of updating the UI.
And there is one of the
new features-- I highly
recommend is the features
two-way data binding.
Now, two-way data binding
when you have complex model
is not very easy to use.
But like all of us
have login forms--
all these simple
form kind of layouts
that people has to fill.
And there's a lot of
logic going in there.
Instead of writing
that code, you
can just let two-way
binding handle all of it
and return your object.
So for a layout like
this, all you [INAUDIBLE]
is create the smaller
class, make all of them
observable field.
Like, you have only one
instance of that clause.
It doesn't matter
how expensive it is.
So make everything
observable fields.
And then when we do that, our
layout will look like this.
We have real data
that enables, disables
the button or whatever logic.
And you have the form model.
And for each of the input
fields, you use them.
So you say, this is the name.
Notice that it's
a two-way binding.
Or you have a button.
You say if my real data model
enables it, make it enabled.
You do this.
So you cannot do this
in every single layout,
so you need to be careful.
Bu something that you can
encapsulate-- it's about forms,
or [INAUDIBLE] place
you want to grab
data-- it's so much
cleaner, so much simpler,
and you will save time.
So just do this.
So now you have a binding
layout that gives you
an object that has the data.
And then you do whatever you
want to do with that data.
So let me quickly go through
some of the best practices,
because data binding
is very powerful.
But just because there's a way
to do things with data binding
does not mean that you should
do everything with data binding.
So something you need to be
careful when using data binding
is what expressions
you put there.
So if you put an expression
like the [? same ?]
and user click this
button, send the money,
you should not do this.
Like, it's so wrong,
because sending the money
is completely about
your application.
This is like it's
your business logic.
It has nothing to
do with your UI.
The only thing you
care about is that user
clicked on that button.
This is where the responsibility
of data binding stops.
So you get rid of this.
Don't do that.
Instead, put something like
presenter::onSendClick,
so that presenter clause
can be tested by itself.
And then you will have
a reliable application.
I know it's not very clear
where you want to stop.
Like how much can I
data-bind, and how much
I should do in the Java code?
Well, you use your intuition.
You know, use what
works best for you.
GEORGE MOUNT: So you're
saying change the name
of our function, right?
YIGIT BOYAR: Yeah,
that was the goal.
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah, yeah, OK.
YIGIT BOYAR: Don't call
[? our ?] functions.
Use [INAUDIBLE].
That will solve it.
[LAUGHTER]
But anyway, data binding
works with program,
because we do everything in the
compile time [? set ?] detail.
So another thing
is if it is related
to UI, just put it there.
You don't need to oh,
my god, I shouldn't put
any logic in my [INAUDIBLE].
It's like that doesn't
make any sense.
If it is about how that
layout looks, if it is simple,
just keep it there,
because the important thing
is when you look
at that layout file
three months after
in Android Studio,
then you have an idea
what that layout does.
That's the point here.
Like, they should
be declarative,
they should explain themselves.
But if you put an
expression like this there,
there is no way you read it
and understand what it's doing.
It's just confusing.
Don't do something like this.
They need to be
simple expressions.
So get rid of it.
Like, create a method
that gives a short name.
And then use that one instead.
If they are not
readable-- if you realize
they are getting long,
then you are probably
doing something wrong.
So it's a method we created.
GEORGE MOUNT: Yeah, we can
also-- something to mention,
though, is we can also do
string functions there.
So if you want to do
string substitutions,
you can use the string formatter
right there in your expressions
as well.
YIGIT BOYAR: So another
thing is RecyclerView.
By the way, two
days ago, we just
published a sample application
that uses data binding
and RecyclerView on GitHub.
And I sent it into the Spaces
link, so you can find it there.
But one thing you
need to be careful of
is if you are using data binding
with RecyclerView, which you
should because it generates
the [? view ?] holder for you,
when you bind a view,
you should always
call executePendingBindings.
If you don't do this,
binding will defer it
until the next layout and
RecyclerView will get unhappy,
because the view didn't
tell us what the height is.
So there's a couple of things.
These are a couple
of little examples
that people did with
binding adapters mostly.
Wanted to mention them.
You can do this.
This is like HTML.
I have a text view,
and it's an image URL.
Well, that should be
probably imageView.
But it's an image URL.
And then it just works.
You have a binding adapter.
You paste it to there.
Everything is fine
properly [INAUDIBLE].
And you know what
that image shows.
You don't need
the ID or whatever
to make it self-explanatory.
It's invisible.
Oh, here is an image URL.
So you can have
multiple parameters.
Binding adapters can
receive multiple parameters.
You could say, OK,
this is the placeholder
and this is the image URL.
You have a binding adapter that
receives these two attributes.
We call it with
these two values.
We [? call it ?] drawable,
and it's an actual drawable.
You don't need to
do it yourself.
And you can
[? name ?] your logic.
It works very well with testing,
because in testing, you just
provide a dummy adapter
that doesn't do anything.
And then now all
your tests run faster
without making
that work request.
The other thing-- font.
This has been requested on
the text view for many years.
We haven't [? invented ?]
it until data binding.
Now, you could just create
your own attributes,
call it app:font,
and then it works.
There's actually a
project on GitHub
from [? Lisa ?] that does this.
It's super cool.
Super convenient.
And you could use
vector drawables.
So [? now ?] today you cannot
use vector drawables in XML,
right?
No.
If you use data binding, you can
actually use vector drawables.
You just create the binding
adapter for that and do it.
Another one here
is-- like, it's so
common in applications
[INAUDIBLE]
dimension image margin.
And then you have something
like a dimension picture size.
Dimension picture size
and picture margin,
so that you could
align your views.
So you create all
these dimensions,
you don't need too many more.
You can just use data
binding to say, hey,
this thing is picture
size plus picture margin.
That's it.
It's like, this should
have been there already.
But it wasn't.
All right.
So once you start
experimenting, these
are things we did
not think about.
Remember the image URL.
There was something we thought
[? about. ?] And that was it.
People came up with this
font, the margin thing.
It's just new stuff you
can do with data binding.
So go on, explore
[? around with ?] it.
Thank you.
GEORGE MOUNT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]